[Musique]
toutes les deux minutes un enfant meurt
du paludisme
aussi appelé malaria
le paludisme est la première cause de
décès des enfants en afrique
6 octobre 2021 l'organisation mondiale
de la santé parle d'un moment historique
in the bread for assigned
ou malraux
le premier vaccin antipaludique voit le
jour la vaccination à grande échelle des
enfants africains peut enfin commencer
c'est une première
[Musique]
plasmodium falciparum c'est parasite
responsable de cette maladie il se
transmet par la piqûre de moustique
femelle les symptômes sont plutôt
sévères fièvre maux de tête vomissements
et diarrhées entre autres
plus de 100 candidats vaccins contre le
paludisme ont été testés chez l'humain
sans succès moss kyrix c'est son nom a
été développé par le géant
pharmaceutique britannique
glaxosmithkline
c'est le premier vaccin contre un
parasite il voit le jour après plus de
trente ans de recherches comment
expliquer sinon denney il faut savoir
qu'un parasite est plus complexe qu'un
virus ou une bactérie
au cours de sa vie le parasite se
métamorphose à plusieurs reprises
mosquée rixe s'attaqua nuit dès qu'ils
entrent dans le foie il induit des
anticorps déclenche la production
d'armes immunitaire contre la principale
protéines de surface du parasite ce qui
limite sa capacité à se multiplier
[Musique]
les tests ont débuté en 2019 au ghana au
kenya et au malawi et depuis on a
administré plus de 2,3 millions de doses
et même s'il nécessite 4 12 sa
protection est loin d'être optimale le
vaccin permet d'éviter 40 % des
infections et 30% des formes mortelles
de la maladie et ce seulement pendant
quatre ans par contre une étude récente
estime qu'on associant le vaccin aux
médicaments préventifs existants
l'efficacité pourrait monter à plus de
70%
l'autre bémol ce vaccin antipaludique
s'attaque seulement à la souche
africaine de la malaria alors qu'il en
existe cinq autres différentes
[Musique]
la course au vaccin contre le paludisme
n'est donc pas terminée en allemagne par
exemple la firme bio ntech veut
développer un vaccin à arn messagers
contre le paludisme une technologie
rendu célèbre par la coved 19
tout cela est porteur d'espoir c'est
primordial parce que depuis le début de
cette chronique l'enfant africain a été
victime de la maladie
[Musique]